Do we need this?
Like, would it make our life?
No.
Is the answer that is no?
No, no, because this takes JSON
and it tries to make it into something that it's not.
Like, it's like, let's take JSON
and make it like a structured, defined, typed,
like property, like, it's like, that exists.
It's called XML.
Oh.
So we've all been on those pentests before, right?
Where we're just banging our head
into the external attack surface of the company
for what feels like an eternity.
And then when you finally get inside the network,
it's like open freaking season.
There are accessible shares everywhere.
CVs are popping left and right.
There's seemingly no controls at all
on what ports can or cannot be accessed.
Too many companies are neglecting
their internal network security.
And that's why ThreatLocker came up
with this product, Network Control,
which makes it super easy to control
what kind of ports are exposed on a given host,
whether that be a user machine or a server.
The thing I like the most about Network Control
is that it understands far more than just the IP layer.
You can allocate specific controls to keywords or tags,
and then use those to manage access from different machines,
regardless of whether they change IPs or not.
So if you're looking to share up your internal network,
make sure you check out Network Control by ThreatLocker.
All right, let's go back to the show.
All righty, my man, we are rolling on this beautiful fall day.
How's it going?
Oh yeah, good. How about you?
Pretty good, man.
The size of the to-do list is growing and growing.
I'm going to Grenoble next week for Grehacks,
and I'm going to be presenting on some Kaido stuff out there.
Nice.
And let's just say that presentation is not fully completed yet.
So that, I don't know.
I don't know.
Some people, I feel like I hear a lot of hackers talk about how,
like, they'll be going to this conference
and they're like in their hotel room the night before prepping the slides
and stuff like that.
And I've never been that sort of guy.
Like, I'm always the guy that like, has it done way in advance,
has it rehearsed, that sort of thing.
But like, I felt like I should try it this time and it is not working for me, dude.
No, dude.
No, that's stressful.
I mean, I'm up for procrastination to some extent,
but like for stuff like that, I definitely, I wouldn't want to really be winning it.
You've got that ADHD brain where you can like procrastinate
and then trigger like superpower mode, right?
Yeah, but that doesn't make the presentation good.
I don't know.
That's the trick part.
Yeah, I suppose so.
All right.
What we got on the news for today.
Let's see.
Dude, this bcrypt thing is insane.
Okay.
So let me, let me just give a little bit of a,
let me just read this, this release from that Okta put out.
Okay.
So it says for Okta orgs without MFA sign on policies
and using accounts with usernames of 52 characters or more,
this could allow users to authenticate by providing only the username
and no password entered or regardless of the password entered.
What the heck dude?
Yeah.
So super interesting stuff.
I, somewhere, I guess in the bcrypt spec,
it says that it truncates inputs beyond,
is it 72 characters or 72 bytes?
52 characters.
52?
52 characters?
Yeah.
So it only takes, you know, up to a certain point.
And then the rest of it gets truncated during like hashing, I guess.
Jeez.
Um, and, uh, they were concatenating username and password together
and then hashing that in bcrypt.
So if your username was too long, then it would just create a predictable hash,
uh, that would never get changed by your password.
And, uh, yeah, very, very,
dude.
I think, could you imagine like, this is one of those things,
like, I want to say a couple of years back,
there was like this scenario with Apple where you could just like press enter
a couple of times or something like that.
And it would log you in as root.
And, uh, yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I forget what, I forget what it was called.
Let me see.
Apple press enter root.
It was, it was something.
With a blank.
Oh, this was in 2017.
Yeah.
Blank password.
Click the lock type root in the username field.
And it was just because root had no path.
Oh, that's funny.
Yeah.
I used to use this quite a bit actually back, back around that time as well.
Just for like logging.
Like I had like a secondary user account.
Yeah.
And I would use that.
Um, so it's really interesting.
It's just one of those things where it's like,
you would never expect that to happen to Apple.
And you would, I personally would never expect this to happen to Okta,
where it's like, there's just no, it just doesn't take a password.
It's just like one of those brain fuck things.
That's like, what is going on here?
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
It's a, it's very, very interesting bug.
So I mean, it's good that it got caught.
How did they find it?
Or like, how did it like, what?
I didn't see, I didn't see the way that they found it.
Uh, ideally their bug bounty program would have caught something, but,
um, this is just one of those things that I think it for me.
It was discovered internally.
Oh really discovered internally.
Wow.
Yeah.
And their timeline.
So July, July 23rd, it was introduced, uh, as part of a standard release.
And then on October 30th, it was discovered internally.
And then they switched from Bcrypt to PBKDF2.
Yeah.
And actually it says down in the comments here, uh, that PHP.net even mentions that inputs
above 72 characters get truncated.
So you had 72 in your, in your head, but they say 52 in the actual disclosure.
Um, so it's, it's one of those two.
I, well, it could be that they have an additional pad.
So like, you know, the speculation I think is that it was username password, but they probably
have like a timestamp or some other thing in there.
Oh sure.
It's like 20 characters padding.
Or who knows.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
But, uh, either way, very, very interesting.
Yeah.
Definitely going to be on my radar because Bcrypt, I think is like something that you see
from time to time when doing white box source code review.
So if you see, if you see Bcrypt at all, I just going to have it in my head, like,
okay, there's truncation happening here.
How might I do that truncation?
And I think if the username was an email in a lot of scenarios, this becomes a lot, a lot
nastier, right?
Like, I feel like the length of that could be dramatically longer and, and result in this
sort of truncation.
Yeah, for sure.
It's, I mean, it's one of those things where I don't know how you would find it, I guess,
from like, I, I would be kind of interested in how they found it.
Like what caused them to find that?
Yeah.
Um, I feel like somebody should have just found it.
Interesting.
Right?
Like if somebody has a, a, a super long username and then they just, like,
the thing is like, if you think about it,
logged you in, like, I would be like, the fuck, like, what is going on here?
I think more of it is like, you know, from like a security perspective, like you'd look at that
code and you'd be like, okay, they're hashing it.
Yep.
Looks good.
They run it through Bcrypt.
They call it standard Bcrypt function.
Okay.
They compare it, blah, blah, whatever.
Right.
But unless you know that like Bcrypt has that quirk or that you've read into the spec that like Bcrypt,
like, I don't think most security engineers would second guess like how Bcrypt works.
Yeah.
Bcrypt.
Right.
So it's, it's very interesting.
It's like a very, very bad edge case.
Yeah.
That's not great functionality.
I wonder, I wonder, yeah, there's not really much, I mean, from an attacker's perspective,
I think it's not super exploitable because, you know, the username has to be so long.
So you can only attack victims with super long usernames or whatever.
Well, and it depends on like how it's being done.
Yeah.
Right.
So like in this case, it's bad because it's username then password.
If it was password then username, that'd be completely different.
True.
But then, yeah, man, they wouldn't, that, yeah, that's a good point.
So it really, you, you have to see that, you have to see that same pattern where they're concatenating
something that is a part of your, you know, a part of the account identifier.
That's like guessable or like knowable, like more than a password or like, you know.
Or static, like a salt or whatever.
Yeah.
Like an email, like knowing the email, not a big deal.
Knowing the email and password is a big deal.
Yeah.
Knowing the email and being able to get it without a password, also a big deal.
Massive deal.
Okay.
Solid.
So, I mean, a little bit of an edge case there, but definitely something to be considering
if you're auditing the auth flows of, of these sort of environments where they're,
they're dealing with this crypt, like password hashing or using bcrypt.
I've been, I've been diving a little bit deeper lately when I've been hacking stuff.
I've been trying to look at least cursorily, cursorily, cursorily.
Cur, cursorily.
Cur, I've been looking at least a little bit at, at, at like the implementation of crypto stuff.
And, and bugs keep on falling out, man.
I had, I had a bug yesterday where I could bypass the, the signing, some, some signing that was being
passed from the server side into the client side.
And, and then the validation was being done in a JS library.
I bypassed something there.
And then let's just say, at a live hacking event in the past six months, there was some crypto related
bugs too.
So I think I was scared of those for a long time.
But I think if you, if you understand some of the basic concepts and then you look a little bit
deeper at the implementation, I think a lot of times those, those sort of issues kind of pop out.
Yeah.
I think you'll find that most of the time it's not, it's not super home rolled.
Like sometimes, sometimes it is, and that can lead to its, its own problems, but it's mostly
just like in functionality, like how it's being used or like they're generating this hash and then
they're trusting it.
And, you know, you, maybe you can poison that hash or whatever, you know, there's,
it's more of like the fundamental principles more than it is like needing to be a math major to
break SHA-256 or whatever, you know?
The one, the one that I, I looked at the other day was there was a JWT token that was being passed.
And, and it was hard coding.
It looked, the way that they had written the code, it looked like it was hard coding the algorithm
that it should be using to validate.
It wasn't even using the, the header.
Right.
Mm-hmm.
But then if you look a little bit deeper into the code, it, it wasn't, it was trusting the
algorithm that was in the JWT header.
So you could just provide the non algorithm and it would still pass.
Interesting.
A lot of libraries have that built in.
Super interesting.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's, let's, let's jump over to this, to this next one.
This is by NDEV TK.
And this is just a write up of a bunch of Android specific Chrome behaviors and
compatibilities and incompatibilities.
I just thought this was super fascinating because I think there's a lot of attack vectors that I didn't
really think about from, from an Android and Chrome perspective that he seems to be really aware
of the threat model with.
So I wanted to get your thoughts on all these, Joel.
What do you, what do you think?
Yeah.
So, I mean, I think a lot of people just sort of jump from like, you know, oh, you click a link
and then it opens the app or whatever, but that has to happen from somewhere.
And so there's a lot of like browser specific behavior, like Android out of the box ships with
Chromium as like the Android web view.
And then I think it probably, most of them ship with the Chrome app too.
Yeah.
Most people are probably using the Chrome app as well.
And so there's a lot of like, you know, intent URLs.
I'm pretty sure that is not like an implicit feature.
It's like implemented specifically by Chrome and Chromium into the browser so that you can
launch stuff with this intent schema.
So there's like a lot of nuance to how that stuff works, the parameters, what's allowed,
what's not allowed, what stuff you can launch, like how it gets parsed, all that kind of stuff.
So this is a really good in-depth like look at that kind of stuff as well as it seems there was
a number of issues with like just the format of it, how it was being parsed and all that kind of stuff
as well, like separate from how it's supposed to work.
So very, very interesting stuff.
They got quite a number of bounties.
I like here how they mentioned some of the attack vectors that I wouldn't really
have known about without going through and reading like the Chromium issues.
For example, apparently it's a problem that can be awarded $3,000 because that's what happened here.
If you can force another browser to pop up from Chrome without a prompt,
apparently there's supposed to be some sort of prompt saying,
hey, we're going to open this URL in Samsung browser.
And the reason for that is because like if you, if like Samsung browser is running on a much older
version of Chromium as a base, right?
So if you can pivot from Chrome and force it to open up Samsung browser, then that makes it,
you know, your chain there becomes a lot easier to do some something like a, like a browser
end day attack on that older version.
Is that accurate?
Is that what you saw as well?
Well, I mean like that, that's true.
Generally speaking, you don't want to make it so that you can open other apps or like spawn
intents from one app to another app.
And especially not without that confirmation dialogue.
So there's this, like this, this concept of registered schemes, right?
And so let's say you have two browsers on your device and they both register the HTTP scheme
and you open a link, it should prompt you and say, do you want to open this in Chrome?
Do you want to open this in Opera?
Do you want to open this in whatever?
And if it doesn't implicitly by like directly opening a specific app instead of prompting
the user to do it, then that's, you know, obviously a vulnerability just like manifesting
itself within the browser application.
Right.
So, um, yeah, it's, it's, it's awesome research and, uh, definitely a lot of good
snippets in here.
Just generally speaking about like the intent URL, uh, schema, like format and like how that
stuff works and what stuff you can do with it, what like the parameters are all that kind of stuff.
So, um, yeah, yeah, we talked about that a little bit, I think on the mobile episode
where we were talking about intent URLs and how all that works.
But I think that is something that like, if you want to level up as a mobile hacker,
like I think one of the next things on my docket as a mobile hacker would be,
I need to understand how all of those work so that I can make my exploits more reliably.
Um, like, uh, I guess, what would it be?
Network?
I mean, you could raise the, yeah, I like the severity of them because, you know,
even if it may be a more complex attack, you might be able to launch it from the browser
instead of like having to rely on another app on the device.
Right.
So then it goes from like adjacent to, to like remotely exploitable, right?
If they click a link in their browser.
Right.
So it still requires user interaction, but it's still, it, it allows you to access some of those
like more intent, some core, some more core Android, um, exploitation techniques.
If you understand how those work, that's pretty rad.
Yeah.
And I feel like there's, there's a lot of crap that ships with, uh, with Android devices
and with like Samsung devices and stuff like that, like a lot of apps.
And so, um, I think there's probably a lot of more ripe attack surface than I, I actually gave it credit
for actually attacking like vanilla Android devices and say like, all right, let's grab all of these,
these apps that come pre-installed and develop exploits that do things like, for example,
opening up specific apps without a prompt.
Yeah.
Well, and you'll see that like, you know, nine times out of 10, when there is a vulnerability
in like Samsung or something, that's like not a kernel exploit.
It is that it's like, there's a permissions issue in one of the system apps that's installed
at a system level that has additional privileges.
And you can escalate through that by doing something insecure through just like a standard
Android mechanism.
Very cool.
Yeah.
I'm looking through some of these other ones, man.
And, and there's like, um, add to home screen spoof.
There's like, um, an iframe escape.
And some of these haven't been, uh, fixed yet.
It says asked and not fixed.
Uh, controlling Google assistant asked and not fixed.
The, the controlling Google assistant one is actually kind of scary to me, man.
Cause it looks like you can, um, you know, trigger the user to go to a, a deep link or
whatever, and it will invoke specific routines or workflows in inside of Google assistant, which
Yeah.
I would not want that to happen.
Right.
Like I have some, I, I, man, my offset is so bad, dude, but I have, uh, I have some, some
routine set up at my house that will, that will do things with my home automation.
Right.
And I'm like, I don't want people invoking that remotely.
So I'm, I'm kind of confused about why this Google app colon slash slash deep link, and
then passing in this whole URL, I'm kind of confused as to why that wasn't fixed by, by Google.
Yeah.
It's very interesting.
I mean, it might be the, it's part of, I mean, you never know.
Like I'm sure Google is not the kind of team that I generally am like worried that they're
mishandling vulnerabilities.
Yeah.
So usually if they have like taken a stance on something, it's very, very specific for
a valid reason.
And like, either they're working on fixing it or there's a threat model, like, or there's
mitigating factors or whatever.
I'm sure that there's some reason, um, you know, I, I don't think I've ever really seen
an instance where the Google security team has like miss valued something or like on not
paid something properly.
Well, it was that YouTube thing a little while ago, but, but I don't know if that was like,
I don't know if that was necessarily like miss payment per se, but they could have maybe paid
higher.
Yeah.
I mean, and to be honest, I often see, like we talked about on the podcast, I think a couple
of weeks ago, or maybe I was just tweeting about it.
I forget, but there's, there was a, um, a vulnerability that was essentially a click jacking
that, that worked out and, and got paid or an iframe injection.
That's what it was.
It was like, and then it got paid, uh, 15 grand.
The Zendesk one?
Yeah.
I, I want to, I don't know.
I don't know if I have a good one.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's a different one.
This is for Google.
So it was, it was a, um, it was a, uh, iframe injection.
So you were able to control what site gets injected into an iframe.
And then somehow he used it to get account takeover apparently, but 15 grand.
Did you ever get clarity on?
Yeah.
I think the, the result of that was very similar to like the, the person wasn't very
explicit about it.
I commented on that and, and they responded and said, um, the result of that was something
similar to that, that Google drive one we saw a while back where it's like, you could embed,
like there was like 15 kinds of chains.
That's what I was talking about.
Yeah.
It was kind of similar to that where you could, you know, force share some Google drive or like
your root Google drive, um, folder, but I think he was able to get his two account takeover.
So 15 grand would make sense for that, I guess.
Yeah.
I mean, I think if you can figure out how to open arbitrary URLs within a Google product,
that's usually like a really good foothold.
Yeah.
Um, and probably one of the more common footholds you're gonna like see, like, you know,
cause they have fairly strict like CSP and like, like CSP evaluators written by Google.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Um, so I'm looking, I'm looking through this whole thing.
We'll link it down below.
I would actually recommend any, any of the listeners that are trying to understand a little bit more
about, um, I guess, intermediate to advanced, uh, like mobile attack vectors.
I think this writeup is really good.
Not only cause it, it talks about some of these more fringe, fringe features, like the intent URLs
and that sort of thing, but, um, also because it, it talks about understanding
the threat models of, um, these various apps and ecosystems, right?
You know, I, I did not know that if you could bypass that little, that little pop-up that says
like, all right, we're going to open Samsung browser now, you know, press approve that,
that was going to result in a, in a bounty.
Um, so understanding those threat models is one of the ways you can really stay on top of finding,
uh, volumes in these sort of more complex environments.
Yeah, for sure.
And I, I think what I'd say is like to that specific instance, just think about it like,
as if it's any other app, right?
If you can open another app from PayPal, that's an issue.
If you can open another app from Chrome, that's also an issue, like without user authorization.
Right?
Really?
I didn't, I didn't know that.
So that, that little box that pops up from the bottom, is that, is that what you're talking about?
Where it's like open with that?
So if you can bypass that, that's a problem.
Yes.
Okay.
Well, today I learned.
Cool.
Well, we'll link this NDEV TK, um, uh, right up in the, in the description.
So check that out.
Um, if you're wanting some more details on that, um, dude, another, another Portswigger research
drop.
You see me, I'm rubbing the hands together, guys.
I'm excited.
I wonder how much they're paying these guys.
Dude, they've been, they crank out some serious stuff, man.
They really do.
James Kettle just hit like 10 years, right?
Yeah.
At Portswigger.
He was like, I love it here.
I was like, dang, bro.
It's a good model too.
I always hear these Europeans, or wait, UK is not part of Europe.
I always hear these people overseas, uh, on the other side of the Atlantic Ocean, uh,
Exactly.
Um, talking about how they get, they don't get, uh, these Bay Area engineering salaries,
but, uh, somehow they managed to capture James Kettle and Gareth Hayes for so many years.
I feel like you gotta, yeah, you gotta just write a, a blank check to Gareth Hayes and,
uh, Kettle, man.
Like those guys are so valuable.
Maybe that's why they raised money.
Yeah, maybe.
They raised, they raised funding so they could pay their salaries.
Yeah.
Seriously.
Um, this one, this one was really cool though.
It's titled Concealing Payloads in URL Credentials.
And I've got a couple of comments on this one.
It's, you guys know me, you guys know me and my clients love of client side stuff.
So I see this and I just, I just want to like give Gareth a hug because this stuff is so nice.
Um, but actually it, it, it originated from Johan Carlson, uh, talking about how you,
this sort of similar functionality, um, on Twitter a while back.
Um, and it's not visible in the URL.
The functionality was in Twitter or he was talking about it on Twitter?
No, no, he was talking about it on Twitter.
Oh, okay.
And essentially what this is, is it's using the, um, the username and password parts of the URL,
right?
So you've got HTTP, HPS, you know, colon slash slash, and then username colon password.
Call password ad.
Yeah, exactly.
So that, and, um, you know, you can navigate to those URLs in Chrome and it just won't show
anything in the URL in the URL bar, but, and it won't show anything in window location.href,
but it will show something in document.url.
Mm-hmm.
So this is, um, this is another way that you can smuggle payload information into a page
without like affecting the actual URL of the page or putting anything in the hash or giving
the WAF anything to work with because it's, it's client side.
Um, so it was, it was surprising to, to both Gareth and to me that location and document.url
are different.
Um, and that, you know, definitely provides some, some ability to, um, to play around with this.
And he, he pointed out really well that if that URL is actually being embedded into a, an a tag or
something like that, and that a tag has a, an ID associated with it, then you can very easily access
that value by using, you know, ID with like Dom clobbering, like functionality by using ID.
In this case, it was X dot username or dot password.
And that will return that string that you smuggled in.
Um, yeah.
So I have a suspicion as to why this is the case.
And if you look, if you look kind of closely at it, um, document.url is a string.
Mm.
Right.
So, uh, either it's crafted or it's set or whatever, you know, somewhere document.location
and window.location is a location object, right?
So it's parsed.
So, cause I was curious if there was like a user name property on the location object or something,
but it doesn't appear there is, but you'll notice that it is, it's a, it's a, it's an object.
It's a location object.
It's not, um, it's not like document, document.url is literally just a string.
Yeah.
So I'm wondering, there might be other instances where that like exists as a proxy or something.
Well, like I said, like maybe there's another object that has a URL property on it or something
that's, that's nested somewhere else.
So that might be.
Well, window.location.href is also a string, but that href is,
Well, that's not going to come from the location object, right?
It does.
And it doesn't contain that username, username and password there either.
Um, yeah.
So I guess is that the location object constructor probably like parses it out specifically.
And then when you do .href, it basically like goes back, it like parses it and then
turns it back into a string.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
And I think, I think that, um, oh, just as a note, I'm just going to mention this before I forget.
Safari does discard the URL.
So this only works in Chrome and Firefox, which is crazy.
You know, normally you see it the other way around where Chrome does something and Safari's like,
Hmm, let me do .
Safari is the new security champ.
Yeah.
So I did want to mention a couple other things, you know, because we talked about last week,
how Safari has some weird cookie attribute commenting out functionality.
Um, but, uh, the, this whole concept of smuggling data through, um, and
in such a way that the WAF cannot see it, I think is really valuable.
And, um, you know, there's a lot of really unique, um, payloads out there for XSS.
But my, my favorite one, which is in line with this is simply JavaScript colon name.
Okay.
That is a full XSS payload.
And the reason for that is that you can assign the name value that, that name attribute,
window.name persists across.
Through clobbering?
It's not clobbering.
It actually persists across window refreshes.
Right.
So I open a window and I name it whatever I want.
I can name it SVG on load alert one.
Right.
And then when I redirect to that JavaScript URL, JavaScript colon name,
what it does is it returns from that JavaScript URL, the name string.
Right.
And then that name, the value of the name string gets considered to be the dom of that page
under the same origin that it came from.
So if I put SVG on load alert one into the name and then redirect to that by a
JavaScript colon name, it will actually render the SVG tag on the page in pop alert.
And there's no way that the WAF can see that.
Yeah, because name is actually always, always exists.
Yeah.
It's a, it always exists.
Mm-hmm.
There's also, I mean, there's a lot of things that actually fall on it, fall into this.
So window dot persistent, all caps is a one.
It just holds the value one.
Yeah.
So, so if you did like JavaScript colon all caps persistent, that would, or alert persistent?
I guess?
No, no, no.
I mean, yeah, you could, you could do, there's lots of variables that are accessible, you know,
at that, at that capacity.
But can you just do like JavaScript colon one?
Does that work?
Yeah.
Well, that, yeah, that'll put one on the page.
Isn't that weird?
Like, like that, that was what freaked me out one time is I like did something that returned
one or whatever, and then I saw it appear on the page and I'm like, what is going on here?
And it's well documented.
I thought for a second that I had found something weird here, but if you look at it,
you know, JavaScript colon name is a pretty popular payload, you know, it's well documented,
but it's just crazy to me that you can, you don't have to do any assignment.
You don't have to do anything like that, right?
If you control the location that it's being directed to, you can just do JavaScript colon name
and you don't have to do any function calls, anything like that.
Because a lot of times the WAF block, they block the backticks and they block the parentheses,
right?
So it makes it really hard to actually call functions.
In this scenario, you can smuggle everything through window.name,
which is something that WAF never even sees.
Yeah.
And interestingly, because name is an empty string by default,
you could concatenate to it with plus as well.
So if you did like name plus one, you would get one in a string.
Yeah.
So you could potentially pivot off of that as well.
There's lots of cool quirks there.
And then, so bringing this back around to the research that they were talking about with the URL stuff,
this is another way to smuggle in data that the WAF never even sees, right?
So you can smuggle in by a name, you can smuggle it in by a hash, or you can smuggle it in via,
you know, this username and password functionality.
And if that username and password gets embedded into an A tag, then you have a really easy way to
access that with whatever ID dot username or dot password.
So pretty cool stuff.
Yeah.
Super interesting.
All right.
Now we got the monster, man.
You ready?
You ready for this guy?
I don't know if I'm ready for this guy.
This is a pretty intense one.
Okay.
Dude, we got to talk about it though.
So there's this tool that got released this past week called Lightyear.
And this is one of those things that, like, I feel like I should probably read through this
and understand it fully.
But when I read through it and I try to understand-
This is one of those things that I'm going to put a pin in it until I need it.
Next time I see a PHP page, I'm going to be like, oh, god damn it.
Here we go.
Dude, that's a good, that's a good, thank you.
That's what I'm doing too.
That makes me feel a little bit better about this, right?
But the TLDR of this, and I wanted to give it some publicity because,
I mean, this is a shit ton of work and a shit ton of, you know,
code that they had to write and intricacies that they had to understand to get us
this tool.
This tool allows you to abuse those PHP filter chains that we talked about on the pod a while back.
And the current state-of-the-art tool for that is, or prior to this one,
was PHP filter chains Oracle exploit.
And they outlined in the beginning of this that there's a pretty big downside to this,
which is that if your primitive is via a get parameter, right?
So if you're injecting into an open or whatever where you can use the PHP schemes,
then if you're doing this via a get parameter, then the size of that get parameter inflates pretty
quickly if you're trying to get data out.
So you can only get about 135 characters out before you start hitting the URI too long problem,
right?
And this tool, Lightyear, not only fixes that, it can dump files of tens of thousands of bytes
with just small payloads of a couple thousand characters.
But it also does it a lot faster and does it more efficiently and doesn't produce any PHP warnings or
errors which will sometimes break the whole flow. So I think...
You don't want that pesky IR team knowing what we're doing.
I know exactly, right?
So this is an awesome tool if you're able to actually inject into any of those sort of
functions that allow you to utilize those PHP schemes.
For me, I don't do a lot of PHP hacking. So this is... I think I'm going to do exactly what you said,
Joel. That makes so much sense to me. It's just, next time I'm hacking PHP, next time I need this,
I know exactly where to find this bookmark. But it's nice to know that they've got something that
really allows you to read arbitrary files with that.
I think that's a really important part of learning is knowing when you should really learn something
and when you should have it ready to be learned. Because there's a certain point. When I was young
and invincible, I had infinite brain space. I am now old and no longer invincible and have limited brain
space. And so I have to really pick and choose what I decide to keep.
Yeah. Yeah. And I think that's absolutely necessary in this environment as well, in the IT environment,
right? Particularly the security environment where there's so much onslaught of amazing research and
stuff. We're in this very small niche of bug bounty and I can't even keep up, right? And it's my job to keep up, you know?
Yeah. And so I think having these sort of categorized and knowing where to find them when you need them
is important. So Lightyear is the new go-to tool for that. It seems like they've solved a lot of the
problems. We can use small payloads. We can do it really fast. There's no errors or warnings. So that's
a good one to have in your back pocket for sure. But Joel, did you see the little thing I added underneath
this in the docs? Oh, I didn't actually, that was the one link I didn't click. No, dude. So it's like,
oh, there's a, wait, but this is old. No. So there, I think they're going to implement it now though.
So I see they referenced this issue four days ago. Yeah. So back in 2023, when this whole PHP filter chains
research came out, someone was like, Hey, we got to fix this in PHP. And, and they're like, nah. And then when,
when this, this, this new research came out, they're like, all right, we got to fix this. So I think
at some point they're going to limit the number of filters that you can apply, which I think would
kill a lot of this research. So yeah, this guy, some, some guy mentioned this. I didn't know you
could do this. This is one of those annoying things about GitHub that you can like, there's always like
ways to like make yourself appear on things. Yeah. And so I guess he mentioned this issue on his own
repo in a commit and it like populated, but some guy has added like a limit to the number of filters
into the PHP. It needs to do a fork of the PHP source. Uh, so we'll see if it actually gets pulled
in or not, but if you want to do that yourself, you can, uh, I guess. Yeah. Oh, it's a PR. I'm stupid.
Yeah. It's a PR. So I think, I think it, I think it should be, I think there's somebody, uh,
opened a PR. Chaining filters becoming increasingly popular primitive to exploit PHP applications,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Yeah. So we'll see. I mean, it still has to be accepted, accepted. I haven't,
it's just going to be a configurable option, right? Like there's plenty of dangerous things that are in
PHP that you have to enable as a configuration option. Yeah. Even though that's a lot of people do turn
these things on, it's just going to be, you know, somebody who's going to be like, Oh, number of
filters, negative one or whatever, like, and, and just then you'll have the same problem. But
for now, at least it'll be like, you know, secure by default, which is good.
Yeah, absolutely, man. Alrighty, Richard, what's on the docket for today?
An ASMR ad. Say less. I got you. I got you. All right, guys. So today we're going to,
uh, attack surface management roles, not ASM. Okay, I got you. Well, if we're talking about
attack surface management, then of course, we're talking about the acid note team, right? The OGs
in the ASM space. And this time around, they've released a new community project, their attack
surface management job board, a place where you can see all of the companies that are hiring for
attack surface management jobs. So if you're interested in that sort of thing, if you're a
recon heavy hacker, or if you just want to get your hands on the acid note product to play around
with it, definitely check out that job board. That's going to be at acid note.io slash
acid note.io slash ASMR. I'm going to make them change it to ASMR. So if you want to support the
pod, or if you want to check out that job board, head over to acid note.io slash ASMR. All right,
back to the show. Let's go. Okay, so moving on to this next one. There's a release from Yes,
We Hack on a tool called Dom Explorer. And its architect, of course, is our boy BitK.
And I just got to say, man, I think I've been sleeping on Yes, We Hack a little bit.
Like, I think Yes, We Hack is actually putting out some really solid stuff, a lot of which is
coming from BitK.
I'm sure I'm not wearing my Yes, We Hack hat right now.
I know, dude. We got to go get our swag because the swag they sent out was really,
really high quality too. But it seems like they're actually dumping a lot of really cool
toys for hackers, right? Because we mentioned before, they've got that XSS exploitation framework,
right? That makes it really easy to exploit XSS and XFL information. And it's got a bunch of
sort of modulized exploitation vectors. Okay, I'm sorry. Hold on, Joel, I have something.
Modulized.
No, no, something like that. But I'm actually going to just totally deviate from this really
quickly because I wanted to mention something that I did the other day that I thought was really cool.
Okay.
So on the concept of XSS exploitation, I was in this scenario.
All right. Story time with Justin. Let's go.
Okay.
I was in this scenario, right, where I had a page that was triggering a redirect and then writing my
data to the DOM, right, via inner HTML. So it shouldn't trigger, right? Because the redirect
would delete the DOM before it actually writes to the DOM. And it's one of those things where you're
like, you're redirecting, but then if it's too slow, we'll let you click this button, right? That does
like a redirect, right? And I had the injection into this button.
Okay.
And so here's what I did. I just wanted to put this on y'all's radar. The host that I was redirecting
to, that the page was redirecting to, was controllable by me to a certain degree, but it had to be
whitelisted, right? So what I did is the domains were whitelisted, but the port was not whitelisted.
So, so what I did is I get, got a valid domain and I put, you know, semicolon one, three, three,
seven. So now it's redirecting to a page that doesn't have an open port on it, right? So it's
trying to set up that TCP connection and it's retrying and it's retrying and it's waiting.
And it doesn't remove the DOM of that page until it opens that, that TCP connection with the next page.
The navigation doesn't actually occur, right? So that allowed the delay to be long enough for it to
write my, my payload to the DOM. All right. But that's not the end of it, Joel. Listen to this.
Okay. So now I've got my payload written, written to the DOM, but there's a WAF, there's a WAF dude.
And so what do I do? I'm like, okay, of course I just use like location name, you know, just like
we talked about earlier. You send like 80,000 ads. Yeah. There's like, well, that, that, that can work too.
But, um, classic move. Um, but the, the, the WAF was really getting in the way and it was, and it was
blocking any function call and I can't use location because there's already a location change in
progress, right? So it wouldn't let me override that. So here's what I did, dude. I didn't actually get
the full exploit to work. Um, what I did was I set window.name equal to document.cookie, right?
So now I've, I've set name equal to cookie and name persists refreshes, right? So then from my
attacker control tab, because I opened this, this tab where the exploit is happening, I can control
where that tab goes. So then I redirect it back to an attacker controlled origin. I reach into that DOM
and read the name property and I can leak the cookies on that page. Um, so it's like,
it's like a holder. Yeah. Yeah. So it's like, it's like a way to steal information out of those
sort of environments, uh, without actually executing any functions because it's just name
equals document.cookie. I'll see you in three months when Chrome patches that, dude.
Isolate the name variable. It's a pretty, it's a pretty, it's a pretty niche scenario. Um, but I just
thought I'd mention it as well because I think there are a lot of scenarios where, where,
WAFs are kind of a pain in the ass to bypass when, when you're dealing with, um, you know,
execution, you're actually getting JS execution, but you can't trigger function calls. Um, and so
having some way to smuggle data back out, uh, via the window.name, I think could be a pretty useful
technique for people. Um, yeah, for sure. So, okay. So the, the, the reason I went on that was that
XSS tools thing, um, which was triggered by DOM Explorer. So now, now we're going to talk about
DOM Explorer. Are you still with me, Joel? I'm still, um, DOM Explorer inspired by Cyberchef,
but looks nothing like it. Oh my gosh, dude. I'm sorry. I, I, I had to rant there for a second.
Ooh. All right. So DOM Explorer, I guess this one's mine too. Cause I'm the, I'm the,
the DOM, the DOM geek. You want me to, want me to talk about this one?
Um, I mean it, it's so basically I, I feel like, uh, I saw, I saw like a screenshot of something
that was very similar to this. Maybe it was during the DOM purify, uh, XSS like a couple months ago.
Yeah. I don't remember. I think Carlson has something, doesn't he? Yeah. Yeah. Somebody,
I think somebody had scrapped together something very simple where you basically just put an input
in and then it would like, you click a button and it just runs it through DOM purifying CD output.
Yeah. So that's basically what this is, right? Where you have, um, this DOM Explorer tool and you can
create a pipeline of, you know, that that's where it's very much so like cyber chef where you have
like steps that you can run, uh, an input through. And so you can say, okay, I want to run it through
DOM purify or want to run it through this parser or whatever, the sanitizer, et cetera. And you can
have this pipeline of, of steps that your, your input goes through. And then you can inspect what
the output would be after all of those different pipeline steps. Um, and so that can be really,
really helpful when you're, you know, trying to exploit an XSS in some specific environment,
you know, it's going through X, Y, and Z sanitizer and renderer and a parser and whatever.
And you just want to really quickly, rapidly test inputs, see what stuff you can get through.
Instead of sending request, wait three seconds, request, wait three seconds. You can build out
that pipeline on the DOM Explorer and test your inputs. And then when you're pretty sure you,
you know, for bypass, you can actually go test it.
Yeah. And I think this is helpful for looking at those sorts of scenarios where you've got a stack
on a, on a open source software that you want to pwn. And it's like, okay, it's using like DOM purify
and then it's putting it into this and then, or maybe it's putting into this like HTML renderer on
the, on the server side. And then, you know, uh, it's exporting as a PDF or something like that.
And you can chain together these pieces and see how they, how they, um, interact together.
Um, and yeah, I did find that, that thing you mentioned, dude, it's, um, it's a lead in Brun.
It's Matthias Carlson. It's a tool called multi HTML parse. And I'll add this to the,
to the docs as well. So it gets put in the, um, in the notes. Um, but I think as many of these as
we can get the better, because there's so many different frameworks for parsing HTML and, and
rendering stuff. Um, so I think that's really good. The one thing I like about, um, DOM, uh,
Explorer, which is the, the one by YesWeHack that we're talking about right now is that, um,
it's actually in the browser. So, uh, and it's set up and you don't have to do like Docker or
anything. It's just like, go to YesWeHack.getup.io slash DOM dash Explorer.
And it will give you this interface where you can play with it. Um, and you can add a ton of
different parsers. So DOM parser, parse five, DOM purify JSXSS, all sorts of stuff. Um, and so,
you know, if, if maybe if it isn't in, uh, uh, this one, this tool, DOM Explorer, then,
you know, it might be in multi HTML parse or vice versa. And I think as we sort of build these tools
up, it becomes a lot easier to find mutation XSS, right? Where, where different parsers are
treating things differently and, um, and trigger those more universal XSS scenarios where you're,
you're bypassing some white lists that are, are like absolutely pivotal to security.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. Um, and there's like lots of configuration options as well on the,
on DOM Explorer. So like, for example, like DOM parser, um, it has, you know, what's the mime type
that you're feeding into it? Does it have a doc type? What selector are you feeding it? What's the
output for like, and so you can, you know, you can really get sort of pretty narrow down on it and
you can, um, make it very, very accurate to what you're testing against so that it works
very, very well. And it's good for testing. Yeah. Very solid dude. Yeah. Yeah. So definitely
I'm going to keep an eye on the, the yes, we hack GitHub stuff because they, especially,
you know, what big case has been releasing lately has really been kind of putting them on the map for
me, I think. Yeah, absolutely. Super, super cool tool. Um, this is another one of the ones like
everything else, uh, bookmark it, put in my, my tools list and then I don't think about it. I don't
think about it until I need it. Um, all right. What we got next here. This last one. Yeah. Let me see.
Yeah. Jason. Okay. I had a bone to pick with this. Okay. All right. Well, okay. So I put this in here
here because I'm like, you know, I feel like Jason is something that we deal with a lot, right? We're
the listeners don't have context to the docs. Let me, I put a link in here that, that essentially
allows you to visualize Jason a little bit easier. And, and the thought was this, um,
is there a place for Jason visualization progress in our, our HTTP proxy tools? Because 90% of the time
we're dealing with Jason, right? The request bodies are, our request Jason. And I feel like,
you know, we spend a decent amount of time modifying attributes and like moving things around and that
sort of thing. And I wonder if it would be better to have some sort of visualizer inside of the HTTP
proxies that makes it easier to, to, to work with Jason. What do you, what do you think about that?
I think the only thing I would like to see is JQ searching. That's it.
What is JQ searching? Oh, JQ like search searching?
JQ format searching. So, so like being able to filter by attributes using a JQ query and just
like put that in a search box. I know you can do it in, um, PAW, uh, now rapid API. Um, but like
the, the PAW, like API tool, it's kind of like postman insomnia, you know, whatever you choose to use.
But yeah, um, it has a thing in like the response format where you can filter down,
um, you know, whatever your, your response is, which is like a query like that. And so you can do,
you know, like dot attribute or whatever, and, uh, you'll only see that in your output. So I think that
would be really nice. Um, you know, this is a, it's an interesting tool, right? So, so this JSON
crack thing, it's like, um, a JSON editor, it's like visualizes JSON graphs, but yeah.
And I feel like this wasn't necessarily the thing that I was trying to like talk about, like JSON,
we can talk about JSON crack, but the, the concept more that I was thinking of is like,
do we need this? Like, would it, would it make our life? No, no, no, no, because this takes
JSON and it tries to make it into something that it's not, right? Like, it's like, let's take JSON
and make it like a structured defined type, like, uh, property, like, it's like that exists. It's
called XML. Oh, yeah, no. And we don't want to go closer to XML for sure. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
okay. Maybe, maybe I'm off base with that. I just, I just think, you know, it's worth,
That being said though, it's worth challenging the status quo on, on these sorts of things,
right? Like I feel like there should be easier ways to modify the, um, the things that we,
that we need to modify in the request body. And actually I've got a solution for that,
that I'm going to be releasing in a couple of weeks. It's not specifically for that, but it,
it can do this as well. Um, so we'll, uh, we'll see when I'll talk about that,
when that episode goes live and we'll see if we still need to address these sort of, um,
the sort of way that we interact with, um, the, these various content types. I, I do want to say as well,
and I told this to the Kaido team and, and I think this is something that is on the, in the pipeline,
but I feel like both burp and Kaido should automatically just change the content type
based off of what format you have in the request body. Does that not make sense? Like, like, I mean,
sure it should be a checkbox, you know, where it's like, okay, you know, do you want us to automatically
update the content type? Like we update the content length, but like, it's very easy to determine whether
the request body is JSON, X, X form URL encoded or multi-part.
Yeah. I will say like one of my, one of the more annoying things in recent burp updates,
recent, I don't know, within the last two years is the JSON, like auto formatting. That thing drives me
crazy when I'm typing in the request and like, I'll put like a quote and then it like adds a new line
because it's trying to format it. And then I put another quote and then it like brings it back
because it's closed the string. It's hard, man. JSON, JSON formatting, I think is a really challenging
piece. So that's, that's why I'm kind of wondering is like, is there a better way to approach this?
Um, yeah, I don't know. I think the visual, the visual editor could be like a nice touch. I just
think it kind of overcomplicates things. And then like, I want to say there was an interface in burp
at one point where they were like, where you could switch the way that the request bodies were
represented. And then it would give you like a text box on the left-hand side and a text box on the
right-hand side. And like, did you ever see that or am I hallucinating? That's how I use my burp.
Is that not how you use burp? What? That's how mine looks. Is that not what your burp looks like?
Wait, wait, no, no, no. When you're, when you're manually modifying the, the request body.
Yeah. You don't have to. Maybe, maybe I just need to, to be fair, I haven't opened burp in a long time,
but, uh, yeah, I think that's nice for, for, I think that that is nice for, for, um, for Xform URL encoded.
But I don't, I don't, you know, I feel like something like that for JSON could be really helpful as well.
I don't know. Just a thought.
Yeah. I know HackVertor does that too with like previews.
So like you can do like a HackVertor preview in the like replay tab and stuff. And it has like a left,
like a input output thing and all that.
That that's pretty rad. I think that'd be good. Dude. Okay. On, let me see if I got permission to
talk about the thing that I was going to talk about. Yes, I did. Okay. They messaged me back in
time. Sweet. All right. So let me just tack this on at the end here of the podcast. Um, and I'll
probably talk about a different podcast as well, but, um, you know, a while ago you and I talked
about on the pod about building, somebody needs to build a freaking notes plugin for Kaido and for burp.
That is good. Right. That, that has Markdown rendering that I found the guy, man, that guy
is static flow Tanner. And, um, and it's good, man. I I've, I've seen it. He's, he's been kind of
working with me. That's the guy I know. Oh yeah. Yeah. Dude, he built, he built out this tool and it,
and it rocks. Uh, I've been playing with it and it's really well structured. Um, the, the Markdown
rendering is really clean. It supports exports. We're working on like a sync feature where it'll sync to a
specific part of the file system. Um, I'm going to use it, man. That's where I'm going to write
all my reports and all of my, um, you know, notes. And, uh, I think, I think that'll be the go-to
methodology because then you don't have to jump in and out of your, your proxy. You can just say,
and, and he has it, um, tied to a key binding as well. So I'm like in my report, I click, you know,
whatever the key binding is. We just implemented that feature. So I haven't played that yet, but
jump into the key binding and then you're in your notes and you're type, type, type. And then
I like that. How do you like that? Uh, and then the type, type, type. Um, uh, so I'm excited for
this. Um, I, I'll link it in the description depending on when this episode airs. I'm not
sure if it'll actually be live yet or not, but, um, yeah, I think it will be. Um, so, uh,
definitely check that out. I think it'll be really, uh, so the, the kind of one will be released by
the time this episode come out. I don't know that the burp one will, but I know that he is working
on a burp version of this as well. And I think this is going to take over the notes market for
the, for the plugins. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. Cause it's just kind of like, you know,
it's like your Evernote or your obsidian, right? But it's just built into, to kind of, oh, here's
the other feature, dude. That's crazy. You can link replay tabs in it. So you can say like,
Hey, you know, this specific replay tab has. Yeah. He showed me when he did, when he did that,
he was like, yeah, check this out. And he, it's like links it and you just click it. It just like
opens the tab. Oh, dude. It's so good. I, why haven't we had that? I don't, I don't know, but
because burp is a swing base. Yeah. Well, that's what he said. He's like, it's so much harder to
code this in burp because it's a pain in the ass, but yeah, kind of, I think because it's, it's just,
you know, JavaScript and HTML, there's a lot of libraries, you know, you can use for that. So it makes
it much easier to dab there. Yeah, for sure. All right, man. Cool. Is that a wrap? Is that
the pod? I think that's it. All right. Peace. Peace. And that's a wrap on this episode of critical
thinking. Thanks so much for listening. And if you want more critical thinking content,
head over to ctbb.show slash discord, join the discord. There's lots of great conversations and
chats going on over there. And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers,
which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts,
and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.